hello I'm eerily Andrew [ __ ]
and you are feverishly watching ghostly
Halloween is nigh and that means carving
faces into produce stuffing pets into
costumes and playing Russian roulette
with type-2 diabetes by ingesting
industrial-strength amounts of candy
perhaps you leave out bowls of sweets
for neighborhood trick-or-treaters I
don't because I believe in practical
gifts and a bottle of ibuprofen for you
ever wonder what goes into the sugar
that goes into your coffee that sugar
you're buying costs more because of
sugar cronyism and a bunch of sugar
Barons are getting rich off us suckers
why big sugar and that's not just my
drag queen name it's a reference to the
special interests who get rich off
government protection the sugar industry
is a big cartel that meters out fun
white powder
it's like cocaine only it makes you fat
and it's legal and much less fun at
parties it's indicative of a broader
issue in our country of crony capitalism
these tiny little green dots are where
we grow sugar cane that's because
America's climate is wonderfully
spectacularly suited to not grow sugar
cane sugar magnates compensate for their
crummy business model through subsidized
loans and laws to protect them from
competition inflating the price of sugar
and ensuring a sweet profit
I said no puns we run our sugar industry
with soviet-style central planning which
granted has historically been a great
way to mass-produce low quality
automobiles and starvation let's say
there's a surplus of sugar the
government has to buy the extra sugar
and resell it at a loss or if the market
price drops below a certain level the
USDA has to activate a sugar for ethanol
program to find the sugar industry new
buyers not many other industries get
that kind of treatment if nobody wants
to buy my jokes I don't get to sell them
to ethanol plants I have to give them
for free to Jimmy Fallon when you add in
the ownerís tariffs the government
imposes on foreign sugar we are stuck
with expensive American sugar which is
also one of my drag names sugar costs
are why Chicago is no longer the candy
capital of the world
why Oreo and york peppermint pattie and
Hershey's have moved out of the country
and why Willy Wonka is dead a report
from the international trade
administration found that nearly three
jobs and candy making were lost for
every one sugar growing job protected
unnecessary handouts are indicative of a
broader issue in our economy sugar
companies have a virtual monopoly on
production but they don't have a
monopoly on handouts here's a list of
other industries that receive
unnecessary handouts
[Music]
slop around a few billion dollars here
and a few billion dollars there and
pretty soon we're robbing Americans and
jacking up the national debt
Democrats and Republicans and
libertarians and Methodists and my
friends Steve should all come together
to stop this sugary graft America's
sugar program is an unwieldy mechanism
designed to enrich a few plutocratic
sugar babies I said no puns and we're
not gonna do
[Applause]
[Music]